citizens of the reject Nation we are back with
a very special koi's Comet Corner catch up on
commercials Edition it's hard to make all those
C's just line up but it does here I am very
excited to watch all of these trailers because I
didn't watch a single one of them while I was out
of town I was hosting all sorts of insane panels
at Megacon I sat down with Daredevil and Kingpin
themselves me and Charlie Cox and Vincent afro
had a great conversation I'm gonna fill you in
in a future episode lots of great stuff went
down there for the great the one and only Carl
Weathers teamed up with James mcavoided tall
sword to X-Men goodness it was it was insane
and most of all my favorite part was I met so
many members of reject Nation I saw more real
reject shirts than I have ever seen in the wild
and so many of you lovelies came up to say hello
so that meant I didn't have time to watch these
trailers because I don't want to watch them on
my phone and I wanted to share my experience of
watching them with you so I have Scout's Honor
not watched a single one of these trailers yet
and now I'm gonna do them live we're gonna start
with secret Invasion we're gonna go right into
Blue Beetle and then right from Blue Beetle into
the across the spider-verse trailer and know
how much I love you because I didn't watch it
across the spider-verse trailer without you
that was no easy feat all I know is there's
a Scarlet Spider frame because dozens of you
sent me that frame that's the most I know of
the trailer please let me know in the comments
which one of these trailers was your favorite
please let me know in the comments if you were
at Megacon and saw one of my panels because
again I met so many of you I want to see who
your names are in the chat and please let me
know what you want next from this here comic
Corner we are going into spring which means
we are going into summer which means it is
superhero season so let me know what you want
to see from this very corner without further
Ado let's get into the secret Invasion trailer
sure Since You've Been Gone
still has the eye patch at this
point much worse oh no iPad
oh you think I came back
this tone reminds me so much of
Winter Soldier which is exactly
what I want I need grounded for this
fight that lies before us old friend
hahaha
this is personal very few of us know about
the walls fought in the shadows
that have raged on this planet
do you feel responsible
it's that big scroll shot was new from
the d23 footage where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight
yes
oh June 21st is so close yet so far okay secret
invasion is one of my favorite runs in the comics
because of its Simplicity where it has an insane
storyline I actually think the modern secret
Invasion comic that just concluded like a month
ago I liked even more than the original but the
fun of the original comic is that it's one of
those whodunits that can affect everyone and
infect paranoia and everyone we had Jessica Drew
be revealed as a scroll and that had ramifications
for you know 10 years prior and five years forward
there's a lot of big ramifications that can happen
with a a story of basically like conspiracy to
this scale I really liked the whole trailer feels
like an Espionage Thriller I mentioned Winter
Soldier during it but all of it feels like that
heightened reality paranoia and there's a lot of
really fun details like the faces of freedom is
the label in front of all the presidents as we see
the new guy we get turn into a bunch of multiple
Scrolls we also get a big shot that we did not
have d23 of these glowing chess pieces of all
these Scrolls laid it out now I think it was very
publicly revealed that Emilia Clarke plays a very
specific role that ties into the newer comic book
series very curious how that relates directly to
Nick Fury because it looks like Nick Fury is using
a mausoleum as a satellite I'm assuming that's a
safe house I'm assuming that's a place he's hidden
out he says it's personal while looking at his own
grave so there's a lot of backstory here with the
skrulls and I really like that the scrolls look
better to me than they did in Captain Marvel
I don't know if that's budget I don't know if
that's evolution of tech I don't know if that's
just because they're darker and grittier but
that Ben Mendelson transformation plus when you
see that one girl screaming look excellent and
that's on a TV budget so I think that the best
way to improve where Marvel is right now is to
have a bigger dichotomy between the cosmic and the
grounded this looks very gritty very grounded even
the Marvel logo looked like it had splatter on it
whether that's steam or blood or whatnot there's a
grit to it that I think is the right move and this
trailer along with what we saw d23 this is about
half d23 half new footage is exactly what I think
Marvel needs to be doing so if you're gonna go
down to two movies a year and two show a year this
is absolutely what half of them should be keep
Marvel on the ground as well as in the sky I'm so
over ready for secret Invasion all right now on to
Blue Beetle this is the first footage I have seen
whatsoever I've only seen the suit so I'm ready
to see what the tone what the flavor what the
feel what the Blue Beetle is let's get into it
me Mr Reyes he finished scraping
the gum off that lounge or what
man I can't wait to see sholo kill enough I feel
so out of reach you always land
on your feet bro you're hymen
guys but do not open it you went in to get us
jobs and all you brought back was the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a
burger you haven't looked
how is that good how did you get
it to do that I think he likes me
oh
that's smart to distinguish from
the Symbiote like that that's cool
oh it's like super like MacGyver
oh oh my space free entry systems ready
what is going on
it's called the scarabs it's some kind
of world destroying weapons it's designed
to protect the toast sometimes it does
what you want and sometimes it doesn't
I I think I cut a bus in half the slow Bow
hand touch nice touch but it belongs to me
no you feel for your family
the universe is sent you a gift and you have
to figure out what you're going to do with it
whatever you can imagine I can create
ah cool haha yeah yeah nice choice a
final fantasy sword that's the move
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a fascist
yes and comic books reference okay so we got
Infinity Omnibus Blue Beetle graduation day and
the original Jamie Reyes stuff that makes a lot
of sense okay let's talk about the Blue Beetle
trailer I'm gonna get right into it this is the
fun I wanted now Show Low looks absolutely perfect
as Reyes I honestly think as far as casting
choices go this is the Smart blend of bringing
in a young audience because he's one of the stars
of this next generation and he's got the martial
arts background I I honestly think a lot of him
is going to be in that suit plus the physicality
even if it's not the stunt work just moving around
in a suit you want someone that knows their z-axis
their use of space their awareness of space when
you've got a practical super suit that suit looks
just as good as it did in those teased images as
it did in those leaked images I've been waiting
to see it in motion and it reminded me a lot of
The Giver there was this 80s 90s movie that was
the Guyver I think it was Mark Hamill and that is
a high compliment because practical suits work or
they don't and this looks like one of those
practical suits that absolutely works and you
augment with CGI just like Jurassic Park all those
years ago the reason Jurassic Parks holds up is
that you've got practical dinosaurs augmented with
CGI versus just purely CGI the weight is different
when there's a physical body in place then you
add to that the family element which totally ties
into the comic book story lines you add to that
the playfulness of someone learning their origin
story learning to use these Powers they go along
it feels very much like and and don't get mad at
me for comparing the two but phase one Marvel
when you've got a new world being introduced so
we think this is going to be the first of the DCU
kind of rollover rolling reboot so some characters
can stay some characters will be rebooted some
characters will be brand new that might tie in
this looks like it could be beautifully
independent of everything else that would
allow for it to be part of the DCU and I really
like the feel of an origin story with him I also
really enjoy the imagery that going out into space
the cutting the bus in half all of that feels very
much like a comic book origin story but my only
concern is this looks fun and everyone has lately
been using that as like a swear word when a movie
is fun people like disavow it I think this is what
we want from superhero movies the sense of play
the sense of wonder the Scarab itself I didn't
realize that Susan Sarandon was the big bad that
is a really fun playfulness that she can bring a
Darkness to this role you know she's an older
actress that's got a lot of Gravitas versus a
younger actor that has all this gravitas I really
like what they can do with the dichotomy between
like evil CEO that wants it for profit versus kid
who accidentally was chosen by the Scarab in the
comics the Scarab is very much like a symbiote it
wields control a lot of times it takes over a lot
of times and it certainly looks like that's the
case here add to that a giant Final Fantasy sword
the playfulness of what he would do with those
Powers this looks like it captures the fun of
Blue Beetle in a wonderful way and I'd love to see
it's a different Blue Beetle in the comic books
but this playfulness with Booster Gold in the
comics it's the first Blue Beetle he's the third
but I think this tone could work with Booster Gold
if they decide to go that way with the Booster
Gold show okay hold on Greg's interrupting
me he's in the room he's right here yes
last frame okay checking the tape okay oh oh
we've got all three of the blue beetles okay
so this is exciting okay I I just mentioned he's
the third Blue Beetle the middle Blue Beetle is
who I'm talking about teaming up with Booster
Gold The Duality so this implies to me that
those have already existed and maybe I'll get my
dream and I'll have a Booster Gold set in the 80s
because it'd be a lot of fun if the future he
travels back from is our near future but if he
goes back to the 80s wherein he could team up
with this original Blue Beetle and then this
being the modern like today Blue Beetle that is
that is yes I'm glad I'm glad you made me rewind
now that's my head Cannon and if it's not the
case I'll be mad because now I'm a nerd on the
internet I would like that to happen all right it
is time and when I say it has been a difficult 48
hours to not watch this when I say that this is
my most anticipated movie of the year after the
first one changed my life I am so elated to
dive into across the spider verse let's do it
thank you the animation in the in the teas
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great all right whatever whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot that's not funny don't don't
do that miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in Spanish I
am lying to you and I think you know it
miles wanna get out of here oh when
oh wait a minute love them already
bug this is unbelievable this is the lobby
Miguel O'Hara the whole thing was his idea what's
it I gotta do to join this spider team you can
you can never be part of this don't even get
me started on Doctor Strange and a little
nerd back on Earth 1999 go easy on the kid he
had a terrible teacher Peter smiles all over
I'll take it Oscar Isaac referencing a
University's in his Moon night is wonderful
you have a choice between saving
one person and saved in every world
I want our spot looks like he plays
into the plot I can't do that I can
do both Spider-Man always always not for
Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be here
one more friends
there's no idea what you're doing everyone
keeps telling me how my story is supposed to go
do my own thing
stop Spiderman
and I looked at my uncle and let me guess he died
wow
that was so much okay so that might be
the greatest trailer I've ever seen I am
so emotionally invested so immediately it does
so much it doesn't reveal too much while giving
you a lot of teases it clearly deals with loss
Spider-Man and being Spider-Man as a sacrifice
it looks like Miguel O'Hare has had to sacrifice
everything in something that specifically miles
does costs miguelo era everything I'm very curious
what that is because it also looks like Miguel has
accepted that whereas miles has to accept that
maybe he loses his mom or he loses his dad to
save everyone and he opts not to make that choice
it sounds like to me he tries to do both whether
he succeeds or not is going to be curious because
this is across the spider verse right there's a
third film I would bet the end of this film is
a cliffhanger between whether or not he succeeds
at doing both if the entire universe and if you
look at the end there's a thing that says text
blah blah to join the spider Society love that
curious but that doing that right after this but
whether or not he chooses to save the every one
of the spider Society the world or the mother or
father he may lose I assume it's his mom because
that shot of uh his dad falling feels like a bait
and switch it feels too obvious so I'm guessing
his mom but what's interesting is in the comics
he's lost both of them they've both also come back
what they've done in the comics is the Ultimate
Universe kind of imploded there's a big incursion
event but when it got reset there is an element
that uh without giving too much away he's able
to do something that brings both of his parents
back both of his parents are alive in the comics
right now and this actually looks like more of the
modern Miles Morales he's aged up a bit uh both
of his parents are still here in the storyline
and it's dealing with him fighting between school
and being Spider-Man in the current comic books
he's kind of accepted the fact that his grades
cannot be as good and be Spider-Man but he's
still in that school there's less Genki involved
in the current comic books and that's actually a
point of contention and some of the villains are
are in that school world so I didn't see Genki
in here I'm really curious if you know there's
elements of his relationship with Gwen that maybe
becomes that sacrifice also seeing Jessica Drew
pregnant uh Jessica Drew as a mother is one of
my favorite comic runs of all time when she's got
a little baby and she's balancing between being a
parent and and porcupine man is her babysitter
it's a whole thing it's adorable I love it so
much but this to me is a seemingly Justified rage
full Miguel O'Hara in the comic books Miguel is
one of my favorite characters because like a
tiny example is his claws are claws to climb
with he actually leaves indentations and buildings
there they protrude and he uses them offensively
so like you can get mauled by Spider-Man 29 like
Wolverine he's got literal Talons on the ends of
his fingers he's a more offensive Spider-Man he's
a Spider-Man that grew up when things were all
bad he grew up in Nuevo York which is a really
rough place so seeing a embittered and battled
emboldened Miguel O'Hara fighting miles is so
special to me because it seems like they really
captured that feeling while not sacrificing
miles's Journey his story of sacrifice while
not sacrificing his Heritage one of the things
I love about Miguel is he's half Spanish half
Irish his name is Miguel O'Hara not a lot of
Irish uh Spider-Man in The Journey so seeing
you know all of that mixed with his character
plus there's literally like Puerto Rican flags
in this background and the snap and these little
moments they're really about the authenticity of
what these characters mean to the culture they
represent not to mention the different art styles
like spider-gwen's world looking like one thing in
his world looking like another and I have to say
the Lyle art l-y-l-e is the artist who designed
Scarlet Spider it's maybe five frames of this it's
like maybe one second half a second it's less than
a second I think it is exactly Lyle's art and it
is the most 90s thing and it looks like I couldn't
dream of what Scarlet Spider translated would look
like and then they showed me it the animators just
gave me a thing that I couldn't have thought of on
my own they just hand delivered something I always
wanted that I didn't know how to quantify that is
the most powerful gift I can even explain how
do you make something in movement you've always
wanted to see and didn't know even how to describe
it and they did it they did that for me they gave
me the Scarlet Spider of my dreams I love that
character so much I'm gonna do a whole comic
Corner about why I love Scarlet Spider one day and
it's just gonna be what I think he represents and
they captured it in in like three quarters of
a second for me I'm elated by this trailer I'm
excited to see that Spider-Man PS4 pops up there
when the point starts and that point joke is
great but it's also going to be very telling for
storytelling I think they're going to do a really
smart thing and make that element a big shift it's
it's it's so much uh I I can't do 20 minutes on
just this part of the trailers uh but I am elated
to see that it's not sacrificing Jessica Drew
spider Gwen miles or Miguel for another story it's
not sacrificing what it means to be Spider-Man
which is sacrifice and it's not sacrificing the
first film's Beauty to continue to escalate and
Elevate the story this looks like a great part
one of two but it also looks like it's gonna end
like Empire and we're gonna need the Return of the
Jedi to bring us forward and I'm curious if that
goes into the Madame web if that goes into live
action if that brings in elements of other stories
um because they reference Spider-Man from
our universe and that's also really messy
with continuity it isn't it isn't Universe 616
616 is the comic books I don't know why Kevin
feige thinks it's 616 he would know but I think
he's wrong I'm with Aman villani and Oscar Isaac
as Spider-Man 2099 here the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is one nine nine nine nine nine not
six one six and it's referenced here I can't
believe it I'm so excited I cannot wait for
this movie I again could do 20 minutes but I
have to stop so those are the three trailers
um overwhelm is what I feel we're getting a
really fun looking Blue Beetle I'm not using
that derogatory like all these reviewers seem to
do with movies that are fun we're getting a very
intense grounded and Espionage tastic secret
Invasion which is exactly what it could be and
should be and we're getting maybe somehow a movie
that is even more advanced and incredible and
powerful than spider-verse in across the spider
verse that trailer that's one of my favorite
trailers of all time I'm I'm gobsmacked that that
first movie came out of nowhere and changed me and
Spider-Man and this one looks like up that so let
me know in the comments which one of these is your
favorite trailer let me know if there's anything I
missed let me know if you agree or disagree about
any of the things I had to say and let me know
what else you want to see from koi's conic corner
I am back home very excited and if you have any
footage for Mega con if you have any pictures of
us from MegaCon you let me know in the comments
it was wonderful to meet so many of you I can't
believe that across the spider-verse trailer
I'm gonna watch like seven more times that's
what I'm gonna do right now so I'm gonna say bye
so I can watch it again bye all I love you foreign